in an advance that could lead to a new
drug treatment for Parkinson's disease
researchers have discovered that
blocking a key enzyme in mice can
reverse the symptoms of the disease so
now we have some initial data that
really supports that yes indeed if you
actually block that kinase activity you
can actually prevent degeneration
reporting in the journal Nature Medicine
a team from Johns Hopkins University
found that blocking part of the lark to
protein which encodes an enzyme called a
kinase prevented the loss of neurons in
the brains of the mice a kinase an
enzyme to inhibit an enzyme that's what
pharmaceutical industries really really
love now the hunt is on for better drugs
that can block the protein I mean this
is research it definitely will provide a
tremendous push in in an industry and as
well as in academia research they're
looking for a better compounds under the
four most selective compounds and more
potent a compound to inhibit a kinase
activity to find new drug candidates
researchers have turned to a variety of
genetically-engineered animal models
which display many of the same symptoms
of Parkinson's disease as found in human
patients you cannot borrow people's
brains and saying I want to look at your
brain of the cell death when you are
still early-stage you have to have
animal models so that you can studying
the pathogenic pathways you can test
genetically what are the modifiers and
you can look at those different cellular
dysfunctions and then finally you can
use animal models for testing drugs dr.
Lee for instance has been developing a
transgenic Mouse with the lurk 2
mutation to reveal the age dependent
loss of mobility in the animals he runs
the mice through something called an
open field test you pretty much put an
animal in the box open box and then by
their nature they need to explore so
normal ones will go around
and the Lark to Mai's they could not
move and so they stay in one place
dr. Li is also working on rat and
primate models of lurk too but others
have turned to a simpler organism namely
the fruit fly the Drosophila models the
finals that we've developed and others
have developed with lurk to have been
quite promising I would say so
we can see some of the same sort of
degeneration process and in the fly
for example the Flies show difficulties
in movement and a similar loss of
dopamine-producing neurons now
scientists are actively testing drug
candidates in all these different animal
models but to date no best compound has
emerged so dr. Yoo is screening
thousands of chemicals with
high-throughput robotic machines so
hopefully in near future I would say we
think Martha so we should be able to
identify us relatively selective
compounds that inhibit of kindness
inhibit activity because lurk -
mutations are found in around 2% of
people with Parkinson's the goal is to
find a drug that can prevent a neuronal
death before it happens because it's a
mutation that you can obviously identify
you know early on even in someone who
doesn't have Parkinson's disease but
maybe has Parkinson's in the family you
could then maybe identify those
individuals those carriers early on and
if the drug is safe enough could
actually start offering maybe that
therapy to us someone who just carries
the mutation even if they don't have
Parkinson's disease yet and with the new
discovery from animal models that goal
might not be all that far off I would at
least be optimistic into thinking that
in the next couple of years we could
actually have a few clinical candidate
drugs ready for clinical testing that
target alert - for nature medicine I'm a
lead organ
you